almost nobody likes their job and so to  me LinkedIn for somebody right now who's  watching this if they realize that they  can post things about their opinions  their observations and their expertise  about what they do for a living if  you're a five-year lawyer and you say  something I'm seeing in law around IP  law and you write four sentences you  make a video it depends on how you  communicate written word or video one  piece of content on LinkedIn where you  have no followers right now can change  the course of your life because now you  have inbound people offering you jobs  instead of you sitting and dwelling  about hating your job